there are two aspects to every donation
there is the emotional spiritual side
which is all good and there's the
practical material side which is very
tricky the emotional spiritual side is
people giving to people who are hurting
which is spiritually evolved in
civilization saving that is all really
good but a donation is a material thing
in a situation where material things
have to be prioritized there's no
emotion in humanitarian logistic
anything that is not needed gets in the
way and so people's donations can
actually prevent people on the ground
from getting the help that they need
after a major disaster there really are
no flat dry spaces to put things and so
if there are flat dry spaces the relief
organizations need them just a stage and
manage and deliver emergency supplies so
if it's raining used clothing and canned
food and bottled water all of that has
to be moved aside and it's in the
elements because there really is no
climate-controlled storage after a
disaster not for a long time if there is
it's used for medicines so all of this
donated goods these donated goods sit in
the elements and they degrade the
clothing gets moldy the cans open up
these big piles become a haven for rats
and snakes and therefore a health hazard
for anyone who has to deal with them and
moving all of this stuff out of the way
and managing it is is relief workers
taking relief workers time and heavy
equipment and money away from the
response so all of these resources that
are used to manage unneeded donations
are being taken basically from survivors
and after the tornado in Moore Oklahoma
a very generous donor offered 28
truckloads of new furniture to the
people of Moore Oklahoma and the relief
workers were like - that is so wonderful
of you but can you wait because right
now there are no houses no houses but he
was excited
that is gift people get very excited
when they're they when they want to give
something they know is special so up to
more came the 28 truckloads and all of
that furniture needed to be where housed
and where housing costs money and so
that's money that comes away from
building people's houses so timing is
important in giving as well and it's not
good to give household goods when there
are no households the best way to help
survivors of any disaster event is to is
through cash donations to the relief and
charitable organizations who are working
directly in disaster affected
communities that is because cash
donations enable relief organizations to
meet needs as they change which happens
frequently especially in the early days
right after a disaster which are very
dynamic cash donations also enable
relief organizations to purchase
supplies close to the disaster affected
area because even in the worst disaster
a protracted famine there's always a
perimeter of healthy markets from which
to buy supplies and when supplies are
purchased locally they are fresh and
familiar to survivors they're purchased
in just the right quantities and they
don't require the heavy transportation
costs and fees they're delivered quickly
and there's enough for everyone
they really cash donations really are
the best donation to give and I
understand that people are sometimes
suspicious of relief organizations and
justifiably so because in that tricky
intersection of money and human nature
there will be pop-up nongovernmental
organizations after a disaster all of a
sudden you'll see this compelling
website with a name you've never heard
of and a big red donate Now button and
people are smart to be cautious but
that's why the charity watchdogs are so
helpful like give well guidestar charity
watch and Charity Navigator where people
who are open to donating money can look
in the web sites and find out what the
organizations are doing what they
specialize in and the donor can decide
whether they want to support the
organization that's really the best way
to do it